[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 les invités voici les
titres la 21e semaine de l'emploi débute
jeudi 23 février tous les acteurs de
l'emploi et de la formation de saint
quentin en yvelines se mobilisent nous
ferons un point avec erwan le gall
conseiller communautaire délégué de
saint quentin en yvelines en charge de
l'emploi et de l'insertion
professionnelle et puis nous recevrons
françois cau sont le président de l'aij
en ce club de saint cyr l'école à
l'occasion d'un spectacle organisé le 10
mars un événement caritatif financer
l'achat d'un robot chirurgical
pédiatrique la 21e semaine de l'emploi
aura lieu du 23 février au 3 mars
les acteurs de l'emploi de la formation
sont nombreux et propose des services
diversifiés pour booster le secteur dans
la région
nous allons faire un point avec erwan le
gall conseiller communautaire délégué de
saint quentin en yvelines en charge de
l'emploi et de la profonde de la
d'insertion professionnelle bonsoir
monsieur loyal
on se marre alors cette semaine de
l'emploi elle débute par une journée qui
s'appelle coup de pouce oui non elles
démarrant à maurepas
bon c'est tout un symbole étant le
premier adjoint de cette demeure opaque
c'est symbolique parce que
nous avons pris enfin moi j'ai pris mes
fonctions début début janvier 2016
il ya un an pour observer comment ça se
passait au niveau de saint quentin au
niveau de l'emploi
et cette semaine de l'emploi donc c'est
la 21e édition l'année dernière donc ça
s'est passé sur les sept communes leins
nous avons essayé d'étendre sur les
douze communes est la première à mon
repas avec l'association coup de pouce
qui est un coup de coeur pour ma part
puisque le président est un monsieur à
la retraite mais fort dynamisme et se
mélanger et c'est très sympathique de
voir ces gens encore attentifs aux
jeunes parce qu'il s'agit bien de la de
jeunes qu'il faut mettre en emploi avec
des chefs d'entreprise du secteur du
sérail en tout cas économique de saint
quentin en yvelines qu'est ce qu'on va
leur proposer durant cette première
journée c'est des échanges alors l'après
midi allait vraiment rythmé sur une
quinzaine de chefs d'entreprises des
grands groupes et pme
ils ont leurs stands ce qu'ils proposent
c'est dit aux jeunes à 14 heures ils ont
chaque chef d'entreprise expliquent ce
qu'ils souhaitent comme type de
recrutement
voilà et les jeunes ont été briefés eux
en un mandat - voilà avec un cv lettre
de motivation et surtout et surtout ça
c'est la clé actuellement la motivation
la motivation et il arrive alors moi
j'ai vu une séance à magny les hameaux
ce extraordinaire qui participent aussi
oui parce que ça marche bien mais
vraiment c'est dire que derrière il ya
de l'emploi et derrière il ya des
signatures de contrats
donc c'est très efficace et puis je sens
vraiment qu'il ya une mobilisation des
jeunes parce qu'il ya un intérêt
voilà et donc ça marche bien mais
vraiment ça marche bien c'est vrai que
cette semaine de l'emploi elle est
vraiment aussi tournée vers les jeunes
qui sont notamment touchés par le
chômage c'était une volonté de
l'agglomération alors
il ya les jeunes parce que il ya
différents secteurs qui touchent les
jeunes mais je tiens à rappeler je
profite de ce moment pour dire aussi que
n'oublions pas aussi les seniors savoir
qu'ils sont très impactées aussi par sa
part le chômage et on ne met pas non
plus à la marge c'est à dire que c'est
ouvert à tout le monde
après selon ce qui se passe durant cette
semaine qui n'est plus une semaine qui
est passé à dix jours oui c'est vrai ils
sont aussi conviés selon ce qui se passe
d'ailleurs il ya un salon qui la
formation au sol un tout au long de la
vie donc ils sont enfin on est tous
concernés par par par ce secteur de la
formation professionnelle
voilà mais les jeunes oui il est
important parce que on sait qu'en france
le taux de chômage de 23 % des moins de
25 ans le monde évidemment on n'est pas
la marge de son département et encore
moins sur saint quentin en yvelines
donc on fait attention à cela il ya les
jeunes il ya aussi des seniors les les
patrons répond présent à la semaine de
l'emploi ils y vont vraiment oui alors
j'ai rien inventé
je suis arrivé aux commandes julie élue
il ya une chose qui s'inverse il
tendance qui s'inverse c'est saint
quentin en yvelines terre d'innovation
et le développement économique et est
force de proposition est très dynamique
et donc les chefs d'entreprise
reprennent confiance aux politiques très
important c'est à dire que je vais voir
des chefs d'entreprise je vais voir des
entreprises
je vais voir des centres de formation
nous discutons donc oui ils viennent
volontiers mais de toute façon il ya du
chômage en france
mais il ya aussi un besoin de main
d'oeuvre il ya un besoin de techniciens
il ya un besoin d'ingénieurs
donc il ya un vrai besoin sur le
territoire donc oui ils viennent y
répondre présent on a tous les types
je rends les différentes journées on a
tous les types de
d'emploi c'est-à-dire l'aéroportuaire on
a aussi l'automobile c'était une
nécessité de créer toute cette émulation
il faut être en phase et bien en
correspondance avec ce qui existe sur le
territoire
je vais nous n'allons pas créer des
salons sur une sur un périmètre de
d'expérience ou d' expertise
professionnelle qui n'a où il n'y a pas
de centre de formation il n'y a pas
d'école et encore moins d'entreprises
dédié à cela
donc on est vraiment lié sur
l'automobile sur nos forces en fait il
faut il faut axer sur nos propres forces
mais quand même il faut être habile pas
ce que il ya des métiers en tension
il ya aussi des choses qui se passent où
il ya des métiers qui vont être créés il
faut être en alerte par rapport à ça il
faut veiller par rapport aux start up
il faut veiller par rapport aux pme et
aux grands groupes la filière donc il
faut anticiper ce à dire qu'il faut pas
attendre dix ans on l'a on est en
pénurie on va vite créer un salon
il faut anticiper avec ça d'où ce
travail avec les jeunes pour qu'ils
soient motivés plus haut on les aide à
viser les les bons endroits pour que je
trouve un travail c'est oui
alors moi j'ai une vraie parole par
rapport à ça les jeunes sont motivés
je pense que nous adultes je suis pas
au-dessus des jeunes mais lorsqu'on a un
vrai savoir donc c'est le métier de tous
les savoirs tout au long de sa vie mais
quand on a un vrai savoir en tant
qu'adulte il faut réellement communiqué
sa auprès des jeunes
les jeunes ont des talents du talent il
des ondes de la motivation c'est à nous
de transformer sa et bien des canaliser
pour trouver un emploi
et bien je vous remercie monsieur le
gall ah c'est vous le 10 mars le lion's
club de saint cyr organise un spectacle
sur des airs celte les participants
pourront vibrer sur du fiddle ou encore
de la cornemuse cet événement aussi un
but lucratif
il participe au financement de l'achat
d'un robot chirurgical pédiatrique
bonsoir monsieur causons cosson vous
êtes le président du lion's club de
saint cyr déjà cet événement il et
caritatif pourquoi mais voilà alors
pourquoi ce choix c'est les lions ce
club d'île de france ont décidé de
s'associer pour offrir à l'hôpital
robert debré 7 robot chirurgical qui
permettrait de réaliser des
interventions chirurgicales beaucoup
moins invasive que ce qui se fait
traditionnellement avec un bistouri
et puis de diminuer la mortalité
parce que c'est quand même quelque chose
de très important chez les nourrissons
ce sont des enfants qui sont tout petits
faire une intervention chirurgicale
invasive il y a des séquelles qu'ils
traîneront toute leur vie et puis il y a
des suites aux interventions qui
provoque la mortalité mais si j'ai bien
compris pour le moment en france on ne
possède en fait qu'un seul robot
chirurgical pédiatrique pour les enfants
pour 7 pour les adultes c'est ça donc
c'est vraiment une situation font en
achetant le plus rapidement possible
c'est ce que nous pensons c'est pour ça
que nous sommes engagés auprès de
l'hôpital robert debré de la fondation
de l'hôpital robert debré pour les aider
donc nos clubs et nous nous allons
organiser ce spectacle de façon récolter
des fonds est abondé la fondation robert
debré pour pouvoir aller le plus vite
possible dans l'achat de ce robot
c'était une demande de
de l'hôpital où c'est vous qui avez
alors nous avons nous avons croisé un
jour le le professeur qui dirige le
service de pédiatrie de l'hôpital robert
debré et puis il est venu nous voir en
nous disant écoutez l'état ne fait pas
en finance des ronds-points en finance
des radars mais on finance pas mais on
finance pas les robots médicaux pour les
enfants et c'est vrai que ça nous a
touchés de nous dire que de laisser les
enfants sur le côté de la route sur le
bord de la route ne pas mettre le
matériel nécessaire pour les uns pour
les opérer c'est quand même un petit peu
cruel c'est donc l'une des missions du
leinster
voilà donc ça fait partie de nos
missions mon ambition c'est c'est
d'envoyer des enfants en vacances qui
n'ont jamais pu voir la mer jamais pu
voir les vacances c'est c'est d'offrir
du matériel a par exemple un aveugle qui
a besoin d'un ordinateur pour pouvoir
communiquer mais ça peut être aussi une
chaise roulante et donc passons à
l'autre partie donc l'événement alors
pourquoi avoir choisi la partie celtes
et bien écoutez ça c'est quelque chose
qui qui plaît énormément parce que c'est
du rythme et puis on a besoin de gaieté
on a besoin de joueuses japonaises cola
etc avec le celtic et bien je vois déjà
dit des gens sourire à chaque fois qu'il
ya des concerts celtic legends se lâche
se détendent et profite de la soirée
alors autant joindre l'utile à
l'agréable en se détendant toute la
soirée et puis en participant à une
belle action caritative elle et dites
nous qui on pourra retrouver là-bas
comme artiste dans la drôme des grands
noms alors ce sombre
c'est ce sont des artistes qui sont
patients qui sont professeurs de musique
dans les yvelines
donc c'est aussi pour ça que nous les
avons choisis c'est un groupe qui a
participé à osny celtique de paris qui
ont participé à brest lorient et puis et
puis festival interceltique et ceux du
bout du monde
penn ar bed voilà bravo et puis ma fille
ils ont raison pendant plusieurs années
étaient les invités du prince albert de
monaco pour fêter la saint-patrick à
monaco donc ils nous font cet honneur de
venir une semaine avant la saint patrick
présenté lors de leur spectacle 2017
ils ont répondu présent directement
spontanément parce que ce sont déjà des
partenaires du du lion's-club d'accord
ce sont des personnes qui participent
déjà dans d'autres clubs à faire des
soirées caritatives pour acheter du
matériel pour des handicapés notamment
dans une école de musique ça permette
d'acheter le matériel pour que des
handicapés puissent aussi accéder à la
musique vous devez atteindre combien
pour 405 al le montant pour le robot
pour le robot pour que les personnes qui
nous regarde là elles vont s'amuser
plus de deux millions on est quasiment à
deux millions cinq pour un robot est
pour l'instant va nous sommes qu'à un
cinquième des ce robot donc cinq cent
mille euros
donc il faut se mobiliser 1 je sais
c'est le nerf de la guerre c'est d'aller
chercher un euro par 6 5 euros par là
d'organiser tous ces événements pour
pour récolter les deux millions cinq le
plus rapidement possible et c'est aussi
pour ça que vous êtes là alors en une
phrase c'est votre moment pourquoi il
faut qu'ils viennent pour nous il faut
qu'ils viennent
venez vous amuser et en même temps
permettre à ces enfants d'être soigné de
façon beaucoup plus légère de leur
permettre de se sortir d'un moment
difficile
et bien je vous remercie monsieur cosson
c'est la fin de ce set 8 les invités
merci de nous avoir suivis et surtout
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]